I'm currently working as external
auditor in the gym to present in the
stream I work in the European Court of
Auditors
in Luxembourg and I work in the internal
policies and banking units I work in the
Directorate General for Home Affairs and
I'm a program manager for borders and
immigration we do the financial audits
of several treaties directed channels in
the Commission just yesterday in fact I
came back from a mission to Madrid where
I was what the auditing of beneficiary
we stayed there for a couple of days and
it was not such an easy project but it's
it's challenging this job that I
actually quite appreciate I completed my
undergraduate studies in Boston Boston
University in the United States I
studied international relations and
Middle Eastern Studies and then I went
to England at the University of Reading
where I studied development finance
mathematics and economics I graduated in
2007 I started economics and political
science
I said economics in Stockholm School of
Economics in Riga for parts of the green
and then I studied political science or
other EU Studies to be very precise in
the College of Europe in nataline which
is located in Warsaw in Poland
what I really like is that when I go on
a mission then usually I'm the
responsible auditor for the follow
mission
so it means that I'm in charge of small
team and I have to really negotiate
sometimes and sometimes it can be tough
negotiation with the beneficiary and to
really kind of be very careful and at
the same time proactive in in doing my
work and I really enjoy that
I find my job very interesting in the
sense that it has this international
aspect and that was also something very
important for me before I came that I
would have this extra to my work my jobs
both of them have taken me to the some
remote places in the in the countries
where we went we went primarily to visit
the project that we were controlling or
managing in the I went to Poland to the
border with the Kaliningrad region for
example and with way Nia to the UK to
Portugal to Greece to all the regions to
visit some museums airports bridges
roads that the funds were building in
the region we met the people we
developed great contacts with people
accompanying us from the capitals and we
saw the impact that the fans make in the
regions and in the country overall in
order for an audit visit to run smoothly
you have to be good at communications
and to be good at asking the right
questions also to be more efficient on
spots and to get the best information
needed for your work I have made some
recommendations in my role as an
internal auditor that were implemented
and that actually touch upon everybody
in the Commission so that's kind of cool
when people you don't know actually you
know are affected by your work
in my current job in the external audit
in fact we are supposed to do about 10
missions per year so that means one
mission per month except the holiday
months or the holiday periods and
usually I got inside Europe so but it's
a new more or less new country every
month Frankfurt London also to Brussels
of course a lot because our biggest
oddity is in Brussels the Commission and
also I have been in Denmark quite a few
times on all this because I do have of
course a language advantage there
normally the work language is in English
but it depends really because if you go
out and in the countries and talk with
the public administration in the country
some countries day they do not want to
have meetings in English and therefore
you do talk in in their language and
maybe take with you and translate them
I will mostly use English in French in
fact we speak informally more in French
but usually documents are produced in
English I also sometimes get to use my
other languages I speak Spanish I
learned Spanish in the Commission in
fact and sometimes I have a chance to
use that Estonian my other language in
the Russian I don't use that much I
think it the European Union it's a great
place to learn languages because you
have all opportunities to to learn more
and also to challenge yourself by taking
these visits going on these visits in
the different countries there is a lot
of young colleagues with interesting
experiences people who have travelled
the world have studied abroad really
it's very interesting and you can meet
people from all over your countries